if you're looking for a little bit of
morning inspiration I'm gonna share with
you a clip from Warren Buffett where he
gives the best advice that he has ever
received you have given a lot of
fabulous advice but what's the best
advice that you've ever received well I
I've received in a variety of forms
perfectly from my father when I was very
young but I mean basically I think
taught me how to live not that I did it
perfectly or anything like that but I
mean he was giving me lessons but he
wasn't doing it by preaching to me he
was doing it by example but basically
well the biggest lesson in a sense I got
is the power of unconditional love I
mean I think there is no power on earth
like unconditional love I think that if
you offer that to your child I mean you
90 percent of the way home and maybe
days when you don't feel like it it's
not uncritical love that's a different
animal but but to know you always can
come back I mean that is that is huge in
life that takes you a long long way and
I would say that every parent out there
that that can extend that to their child
at a very young age it's gonna make for
a better human being and you felt like
you've got that kind of unconditional
love from your bed I absolutely did you
know there's a powerful thing it is a
powerful thing now I'm gonna be honest
with you when I was researching clips I
wanted to have one from Warren Buffett
and I was researching clips I came
across this one it struck me as being
impactful but I thought I'm not gonna
put this on my channel because it's not
related to business you know my channels
for entrepreneurs I always show business
stuff on here this is great it'll help
me as a father as a son as a husband but
I wanted to share something a little bit
more business with you guys so we
actually had a different clip picked out
that I was gonna use and I'll tell you
why I use this one instead this morning
for whatever reason I woke up thinking
about Warren Buffett's advice and as my
wife's alarm went off I went closer to
her and just touched her and hugged her
and wished her good morning and just
wanted to show some extra love towards
her
I got up I made her her breakfast of the
day and got her the vitamin water that
that I usually drink in the morning and
stood by the door she drove off to work
and I felt so much more love for her and
just wanted her to feel loved in return
and wanted her to have a loving start to
the day and I felt in that moment man
Warren Buffett's advice you know it
really hit me and it really impacted my
morning and I felt like you know the
point of this morning series was to
share things were having an impact on my
life and since this had a big impact on
my morning I thought I was gonna share
it with you now the more I thought about
it I also realized that this could
really have an impact on your business
you should love and show love to your
team into your customers into the
community that you work in now may not
be the unconditional love that Warren
Buffett is talking about I don't expect
you to love your staff as much as you
may love your children or your husband
or wife but showing them love and having
them know that even if they make
mistakes you've got their back can go a
long way to helping them be confident
and build great things for your business
and I think about why I'm doing these
videos and why I started the channel and
the love that I have for you guys and
wanting to see your businesses take off
and your day go amazingly well so today
I just wanted to spread some love and I
hope you guys will have a love filled
day and spread love to others as well
I'd love to know what you think about
Warren Buffett and his advice if you
want to leave a comment below I'm gonna
be joining in the discussion and look
forward to seeing you there of course
remember to believe have a great day and
I'll see you soon